in any way do you feel that safety was
compromised by the fact that ethnic
minorities and women if I may finish the
question were favored over others
okay there was there was absolutely no
drop in operational standards no drop in
any standards there was no discriminate
discrimination against any any group but
as I say today you know we've been very
clear on that but today we are here to
to focus on the loss of uh her late
Majesty the queen and focus on what we
will do to contribute to to that to the
National morning yeah her role was to
uphold Law and Order do you think the
law was broken by the Aria
well as I said there were no no
standards were dropped there was no
discrimination against any group and I'm
yeah and you know I'm I'm here to to
talk about the uh you know what the
Royal Air Force is doing and the Royal
Air Force is a phenomenal record of
operational delivery from uh from the
north of Norway through to the
Mediterranean defending NATO airspace
defending our allies
we're in the Middle East tackling uh
threats to our security from the from
the the pernicious violent extremists
and we thank you for yourself what's the
service of your personnel and and
nothing that uh you know no approach to
recruiting or any um any measures that
we've we've taken to recruit from the
widest pool of talent in the UK
Workforce has uh has in any way
um detracted from that from our
operational standards and our
operational service one of the thought
before we move on what's happened to the
senior leadership that was responsible
for those practices
well we've been very clear on where we
where we stand on that and I
I made a video tribute to
Her Majesty the late Queen
over the weekend and and I recall
standing here standing on the Battle of
Britain forecourt where
Her Majesty vividly recounted her
experience of seeing and her memories of
seeing the Battle of Britain fought and
won in the skies above London in 1940.
and that that link to the Royal Air
Force those you know that that that
sense of history that she she brought
that that constancy in everything that
we've done to protect the nation over
over the 70 years of of her Reign and
will continue to do into the future I
think that's what matters today and
that's what I'm going to be focusing on
and she appreciated very much the
service uh by your military personnel as
I'm sure the Future King will as well
but you know to ask the question again
what's happened to the senior leadership
that we're responsible for those
practices well we've been we've been
very clear where we've been very clear
where we stand on that
the as as part of the as part of the
work that's been been going on we've
we've said as I said we've been very
clear where we stand we will continue to
examine our practices we will do
everything we can to recruit from the
widest pool of talent in the UK
Workforce because we need to and and we
will do that without any drop of
operational standards we will be very
clear we will be very clear about how we
how we uh how we have approach any
attempts to widen that pool of talent
widen our diversity and we will continue
to to protect the nation uh we we will
secure our skies and and Patrol our seas